as i mentioned last friday there is
uh one more topic that i want to cover
and that is the topic of diffusion and
so today i'm going to talk about
uh diffusion which uh and will be in the
context
of what diffusion depends on
and how do we describe it um and in
particular there's two laws
fixed first law and fixed second law
that i want to talk about and i want to
talk about how
this looks in the context of some of the
chemistry that we've learned some of the
things that we've learned
so diffusion is is this is kind of a
standard
picture people show for diffusion
although really this is
probably mostly convection right uh but
it which is the movement you know
it's not diffusion um but but diffusion
kind of has taken on this broader
meaning
right and so what what do we mean by
diffusion well
diffusion comes from the latin word
defundere and that means to spread out
okay but c to spread out but in in
in this class um we're going to start
by thinking about it as a a particular
movement down a concentration gradient
and that is what's happening here right
like
you see this is a very concentrated
droplet of dye that you put in there and
then
it's less concentrated out here you
probably don't have any
all right so the concentration of the
dye out there is zero and in here it's
very high
and so it it wants to go down
a concentration gradient so that's
movement
down a concentration gradient
concentration
gradient okay
how do we describe this movement and and
it really it goes back to
experiments that robert brown did and
this is the original paper
that he wrote way back in the 18 early
1800s
i love the title of this paper a brief
account
of microscopial observations made
specifically in the months of june july
and august 1827
on the particles contained in the pollen
of plants and on the general existence
of active molecules in organic and
inorganic bodies
what a nice detailed title
that was bro now this motion so he was
he started with pollen
okay and and he looked at it and it
looked like this
that's very loud
great there wasn't supposed to be music
so that
that's what he saw except this isn't
what he saw this is what
koshu endo randomly posted online and
i'm showing you
um but this is if you looked at pollen
in a microscope and you're robert brown
back in the early 1800s
you'd see this and so we thought aha
okay there's life this must have to do
with biology
you know and things are alive and so
they move
right it must be something like that and
so
you put other things in and they did the
same thing they jiggled around
right and then he said well okay what
about if i put
something that was once alive but not is
not alive anymore it did the same thing
it's okay wait a second maybe there's
something to do with having ever been
alive
the spirit of the particles right and so
okay
the ultimate experience i'm going to
break some glass which is what he did
i love that i like breaking glass too
and so
he broke the glass and he took little
pieces of glass and put it under his
microscope they did the same thing
they all did the same thing right so
they were really
what was going on this is the
microscopic basis
this this is now called brownian motion
it's random motion
due to thermal energy and collisions
um and and and it was it's the
connection of this
microscopic random motion due to thermal
energy
and macroscopic observables that led to
a big advance in our understanding of
diffusion
right and and so the question of how far
took almost 100 it took 80 years right
so you say one of the first questions
say how far do these things go
man how far are they gonna they're
randomly moving around i got that i see
in the microscope
how far do they go so how far
[Music]
well that was a question that
you can answer if you can get the mean
squared displacement mean square squared
i don't know i say tomato and and so
displacement it's like you know
it's okay and mean square displacement
and and it really came from einstein
in in 1905.
actually this is what einstein did for
his dissertation his phd work
was on this topic it was on
understanding how to go
from these kind of microscopic
flux random fluctuations to some
macroscopic observables
and so the if you the mean square
displacement well that's just
you know it's the average of some
some measurement of some distance the
particles go so if we go
you know if you look go back to the dye
there it is but now it's in atom form or
molecule form
and it's diffusing around diffusing
around and and okay you say well how far
did it go
that would be the circle and and that's
something that einstein tackled in his
phd
and found that the mean square
displacement is
well let's just okay it's equal to six
times some constant times time
this is in three
dimensions oh if you're in two
dimensions it's four
if you're in one dimension it's two
but the main point isn't that the main
point is that the mean square
displacement
is a function of some constant times
time
right and and so so if you just wait
long enough and you know this constant
then you can figure out how far things
diffuse that was pretty cool
that was pretty cool but you see okay
now what we're gonna
be more interested in in this class is
not
how far but how fast we're interested in
how fast
so if we ask and again these are
questions
that brown couldn't answer brown
observed these things
and wrote about them and that's why it's
called brownie emotion but it was
later that people said well let's try to
think about how to write this down and
come up with theories
that explain it and so for how fast
now we have uh the flux so we have the
flux
or the diffusion flux j right
and we what we want is a way of
describing
how much so it's an amount okay so it's
an amount
of something substance substance
now the amount of the substance per area
you're going to normalize it so you say
i'm going to take like this sheet and
i'm going to say how much of it is
crossing this sheet
area per time right so that's
so substance amount of a substance
per area
per time
that's the flux did the the time okay so
like
it could be grams the amount could be
grams right at
mass kilograms micrograms
nanograms right it could be
number of atoms moles that's also an
amount right moles
right so we'll just say amount that's
general grams
moles right etcetera
n number of atoms that's that's mole
that's what moles tells us
right uh grams etcetera uh oh the time
could also be
oh the area could be centimeters squared
meters squared right it's an area and
and then the time is is usually seconds
usually it doesn't have to be
right and so this is what fixed law
gives us
so this was first
established how do you get a dependence
of this flux
right how do you get a dependence of
this fox and again we got this constant
in there
and fixed first law is all about that
fixed first law
says that this flux is
proportional to and i'm just going to
write it like this for now concentration
concentration gradient
right so that's like the change in okay
c divided by the change in x and then c
is concentration
here we'll draw an arrow concentration
is c
right well we could use brackets you
know bracket a
concentration of a right mass per liter
something like that
well i'll use the the letter c delta c
over delta x so that's the concentration
gradient
and what fix what fick did oh by the way
this was also my
this wasn't as as far it didn't take as
long as einstein but this was 18
uh let's see 55.
okay good so fit came along
uh maybe 30 years later and he said well
i want to know how fast things are going
i want to
understand how to describe the flux of
these
these randomly moving things and i
notice
that it depends on the concentration
difference right and in particular
i like it when things are when diffusion
is positive
so j is equal to minus d
times dc dx and that is
fixed first law goes in tight
and d is a constant is this constant
again so d is the diffusion constant
we'll talk about this diffusion
constant there's the concentration
gradient
and and we got a minus sign
notice oh movement down a concentration
gradient
notice if i if i didn't have a minus
sign then i wouldn't have a positive
flux
then the droplet wouldn't spread out
that wouldn't be good right so we're
going from high concentration to low
concentration when i've got a bigger
change in the concentration i've got
faster diffusion that's what fixed first
law tells us
okay good very importantly fixed first
law
means it's steady state steady state
notice there is no t here
there's no time for that we have to wait
for the second law
so steady state diffusion
and that means not
a function of time not a function of
time
so what you the the kinds of problems
where fick's first law matters
is and i know some of you probably seen
fixed first law i get that but we're
going to
in a little bit we're going to connect
it to crystals right
but so the kind of diffusion where the
first law matters is the kind where
we you might you're holding
concentrations equal let's say you're
holding a concentration gradient
and it's not changing and so you're
wondering
well if i hold a concentration at one
thing here and at another thing here
how fast do things diffuse that's what
fixed law tells us
right and so let's do let's do an
example
here's my example i found these gloves
because i was looking for
copolymers called polymers right here's
a copolymer
that doesn't have the nitrile groups
remember the nitrile groups last friday
they were so important when we're doing
our polymer design this doesn't have it
these are just butyl
this is butyl rubber okay fine so
there's the copolymer
right it's called polymerized with these
two uh groups but
uh and it but now it it's got those
those groups because it gave me the
right maybe
flexibility and some of the other
factors that i want in the glove
but is it strong enough chemically and
that's a
very important question we talked about
this slightly you know last friday that
these these chemical groups change the
mechanical properties they also change
the chemical resilience
right uh and so so here i have it i have
a toxin this is why we wear gloves
because we don't want to get methyl
chloride
into our skin methyl chloride is toxic
at 50 parts per million
keep it out all right be very careful
so i don't know i mean i know i look up
online i say well okay butyl rubber
these feel comfortable but
how are they okay with methyl toxin
methyl chloride which is a toxin that's
a molecule
it has a diffusion constant of 1 times
10 to the minus 6 centimeters square per
second
the gloves are 0.04 centimeters thick
and i'm i'm working with paint remover
right i'm working with paint remover the
the concentration of paint remover is a
gram per centimeter cubed
am i safe how long
how much am i going to be exposed to
this that my skin i'm starting out with
zero what's the flux through the glove
right can i stay safe well first of all
we can we
one thing that we can do is we can look
at
just to make sure we understand so this
is a diffusion constant
you know why does it have those units
well the units you know
you can see this right like the units of
j
are like an amount
right this is what we already said
divided by
an area times a time
so if the units of c
are an amount okay i stayed with grams
right over a volume
then you can see right away that
diffusion
must be
area
over time it has to be
if it's not then this does the units
don't work
right i've got concentration over a
length
this is a 1d right i'm going across some
some membrane maybe or some area
right this is a membrane the glove right
and so you can you can think about this
for yourself the units have to be
uh uh area over time right is it area
over time
ha centimeters squared per second
it work okay so that worked
now the other thing is
you know before i before we do the math
why does this happen
anyway right why is there diffusion and
this is
you know it's it's actually quite
straightforward to understand
even when you go all the way back to
brown's
experiments with pollen you say things
are moving randomly
why is there now a direction right why
is there now a direction
how is that possible how can there be a
direction
if if it's all random
how can there be a concentration
gradient then you can you can get that
because if you have some
like high concentration let's suppose
that this is a high
concentration and this is a low
concentration
and you know you got the brownian stuff
going on
right you got it it's all you know in
something you know there's brownie
emotion whatever containers they are
these are whatever is in whatever it's
got brownie in motion
and so but that means that it's because
it's random it's equally likely to go
that way
as it is to go that way okay but so
but see where so but see at the high
concentration
i've got more particles
you can see that because i drew bigger
longer arrows so it's obvious
more particles because it's more
concentration there's just a lot more of
them so there's more
going across like you know if i try to
draw a boundary here
and or boundaries inside here and i look
at those as my areas right
there's a high concentration there's a
lot of stuff going randomly back and
forth across and down here
you can do the same thing but there's a
lower concentration so there's less
stuff going back and forth
across those barriers right and now i
bring them together
i bring them together i bring
the methyl chloride to the glove
to my hand right or
i bring something with a high
concentration next to something with a
low concentration
and i keep the concentrations of the
endpoints
fixed i hold these fixed fixed first law
tells me
now how this happens and you know that
if i bring them together now well look
this was going just a little bit back
and forth and this was going
a lot bit back and forth and so there's
going to be
a net diffusion that way right there at
the edge you can see it
more goes to the right then goes to the
left
and so this starts to create a diffusion
gradient
that'll create a diffusion gradient
right
so that's why it works that's why
concentration gradients
cause diffusion and first law tells us
how okay well let's answer so if we go
to the question
so let's see so the j so now i've got my
my glove and so the j is equal to
uh let's see it's minus 1.1
times 10 to the minus 6 centimeters
squared
per second times and this is going to be
let's see uh okay i started with
what i started with one gram
right per centimeter cubed and on the
skin i've got zero
okay so it's going to be times zero
minus one
gram per centimeter cubed and
that's going to be divided by the
distance 0.04
centimeters and this goes to
something like um let's see
2.5 times 10
to the minus 5 grams
per centimeter squared second
that's the flux that's what fixed law
tells us because
my skin is good enough my body's good
enough to that anytime a toxin a methyl
chloride molecule touches it
it the skin just takes it away
and poisons me so but no but that's
important i mean it's
it's not good but it's important because
it keeps
this concentration fixed right now
otherwise this would build up
and it would be changing so you can't
use fick's law
right no no fixed law it applies when
you've got these two concentrations are
fixed
and there's not a time dependence right
instead there's a rate
there's a flux that you're after jay
okay
all right and so now you say well this
is can i can i handle this
can i handle this and work it out 50
parts per million
right should he use the nitrile
should have used the nitrile copolymer
go back and make new polymers
right maybe you need much much better
chemical resilience which might lower
this diffusion constant right
this is serious stuff this is serious
stuff
and it's so serious that i want to talk
about eggs
so because you can make so okay
the the rubber glove stops this toxin
oh it slowed it down did it slow it down
enough
might do them you know use fixed first
law yeah but
but you can make membranes that are
actually very selective
it's the coolest thing right you make a
membrane that only allows water to go
through
but not salt right that's a selective
membrane
right and that's called osmosis when you
can allow
one fluid to go through it's
semi-permeable
permeable to one type of fluid but not
another and the egg is such a great
example i had to show you this video i
made this
years ago in another class and
and because i wanted to show it this is
what you can do with eggs okay they're
so cool
here's the video so you soak them in
vinegar okay it's even it's even got
directions and everything we don't need
any volume and there they are okay
you're still going vinegar now the
vinegar
dissolves the calcium carbonate you know
this well you've done these these
reactions
right so there you go you soak in a
vinegar leave it overnight i'd say is
probably
then you peel off the vinegar and look
there's a membrane
the egg has a really cool membrane this
isn't cooked this is just a raw egg
but now i add a bunch of syrup okay now
the sugar this is almost pure sugar but
so so the
concentration gradient is enormous
because the the liquid inside the egg
doesn't have any sugar in it
but outside the liquid has huge amounts
of sugar in it
so the water inside the egg wants to
diffuse out eight hours not well it's
kind of enough
in 18 hours you pick that membrane up
it's a really cool membrane the egg
membrane
it's a semi-permeable membrane and it's
hard to see here but you see all the
water is kind of gone
it's totally deflated but completely
stable because the membrane's that
strong
the water inside has left and and then
if you
if you get some green dye and you put it
back into some green water then you can
make
green eggs and you can make green ham
that way
and that's osmosis right and and so
so but it's semi-permeable
you got to give the credit right you got
to give the credit right
in these things this was years years ago
when i thought i had a career in that in
that
in that direction um so
the egg is just such a cool membrane to
play with and i went down to most of us
can access an egg i thought if you want
to play with a really cool some people
send me permeable membrane that is is
cool and you really will see
fixed first law right at play you will
see it and you will feel it
um okay now uh um
there's one thing i want to comment on
about all this stuff and i
we are not going to learn the details of
entropy
in this class that is really something
for a thermodynamics class
but i got to just correct something
because it's in your textbook
because you know a lot of this diffusion
stuff
and and in fact dissolution we talked
about like salt dissolving we did we did
whole lectures on this the dissolution
remember these all have to do
with the total energy of the system the
total energy of the system
but you know we really focus in this
class on one part of that
on one part which is called the enthalpy
the bonding
right the bonding the potential of the
body there's a whole nother part
that's related to the entropy and and
i'm not we're not going to go into this
in detail like i said this won't be
you won't be tested on this but i got to
bring it up because
so entropy can be really important
why does something dissolve it may be
dominated by entropy
it may be dominated by entropy not all
the but that goes into the total energy
still
so we still have our happy place you
know of
lower energy better but as you learn
more
about what that energy entails you got
to start including entropy
in the future so april says
oh for now we can state that entropy is
a thermodynamic property of all
substances that is proportional to
their degree of disorder
no that's not true
that is not true so i i have a question
okay
so people you see this all the time
entropy
higher entropy more disorder my room is
messy it's got a high entropy
so which of these has a higher entropy
which one of these has a higher entropy
and which is lower
right this is a very simple grid they've
got the same exact number
how many think that the one on the right
is you know it's a smoother one right
how many think that this is the lower
entropy system
i've set this up i've set this up
because you know
that's not but why the reason is the
real reason
for what entropy is it's not simply
disorder
because in this these are computerized
experiments
so we told the computer to pick randomly
uh
you know a place on a grid a certain
number of times and then fill it in
but in this case you restricted it you
said no
i can't have any two squares next to
each other
and in this case you simply did it
randomly so
this looks smoother this looks
less disordered but this
has a higher entropy why because
you have fewer options and that is what
entropy is about
entropy is about the number of
possibilities
that you have now you know that might
look more disordered it might not
but that's what it's under the hood of
entropy is possibilities it's number of
states
of accessible states you know assault
uh atom in the crystal has very few
possibilities
if it were a perfect crystal one it's
got to be
in the lattice right but once it goes
into the liquid it's got many more
possibilities it's those numbers of
states that matter
right that's why it's entropy goes way
way up
it's the number of possibilities the
number of possible
states okay good that was my aside on
entropy
now i want to get to so okay so we
talked about
fixed first law we talked about
diffusion we looked at drops and
we made sure the gloves we choose are
going to be safe
what about solids right what about
solids well
things diffuse around in solids too
here's a red atom
that is going to diffuse watch this
super high-tech video
okay how does it do it a vacancy comes
in look at that vacancy
moving around moving around bam
that atom moved it moved right
self-diffusion it moved it's a it's a
single it's an atom of the same type
you know that was able to move in the
lattice because a vacancy
diffused through right and so there's
the the beginning
and there's the end you see it moved
over by one position but now we're all
thinking
we're all thinking and we're going back
to our days
of well okay hold on um
what really happened right so here's the
here's the vacancy on one side here it
went over to this side
there's the atom going through right so
the vacancy moved that way the atom
moved that way
but as you know that atom had to
experience
some barrier so it had to get over some
activation
all right it had to get over some
activation and that really helps us
answer a question that has been burning
in our minds this whole lecture
which is what else does flux depend on
we saw the concentration gradient thing
right
we we looked at in very simple terms we
understood it
but what about b itself right well
when you see something that's an
activated process there's only one
person that ever comes to mind right
first name s last name a
and it's fonte because you know that if
it's an activated process then there's
some
pre-exponential factor times the
activation energy divided by kbt
if it's for a single atom or if it's a
mole you use r
there's your activation energy right
there
and but so now we can start connecting
this so the
so one thing you know about that
diffusion constant is it will have a
temperature dependence
right and and you also know now
that if you plot the log of it versus
one over t
you will get that oh we're back we're
like in our happy place
with this right
so so this is this is an activated
process for an atom diffusing
and this would be you know maybe you
know these these these kind of
atoms diffusing through their own last
remember
these these have high barriers this this
might be kind of hard to do but it's
still going to happen
it's still going to happen you might
also get something like this and this
goes
back to our discussions of defects in
crystals
you you might get an interstitial
diffusion
right so this is diffusion
this is the topic that we're covering
but now we can relate
the equation that governs diffusion the
d
to the crystal and to the chemistry
right because what is the barrier that
that feels when it goes through so
remember an interstitial
like carbon and iron right carbon and
iron to make steel
right that would be an interstitial uh
you know defect or an interstitial atom
that you've added to the system
to the iron lattice and how does it move
well that's absolutely critical because
it tells you how to make it
right and we'll get to an example of
that um so so like if i look now at
these plots
and these are plots i think i showed you
back when we look talked about
interstitial defects
you can really connect it to what we've
learned
so just to start like okay these are the
log diffusion coefficient so that's the
diffusion coefficient that we're talking
about right there
and versus 1000 over t so it's one over
t scaled by a thousand and
and these are those oh beautiful cevante
arrhenius dependencies right and and
these are experimental measurements
and look here's i here's hydrogen in bcc
iron here's hydrogen in fcci now notice
at the same temperature right at the
same temperature
there's a huge difference and then i
don't have i have fcc up here
right and then i've got bcc over there
why well those are the stable phases at
those temperatures
but notice that when they're at the same
temperature there's a huge difference
why
because you know from the crystal
structure
that there's more room right so the
activated
barrier the activation barrier will be
lower
in bcc those voids are bigger there's
more space it's not as well
packed we've covered that right
and look at this so there's hydrogen is
really small there's iron
iron and bcc fe compared to hydrogen
bccfe look at those orders of magnitude
so there's an iron atom diffusing in its
own solid
and here's hydrogen atoms you can see
there's carbon and so forth right
so this is the the picture that comes
back if we want to think about diffusion
in solids
we can connect it to the packing and
crystal structures
because we know that these atoms these
interstitial atoms are going to diffuse
through the interstitial
space what is the interstitial space
well here
as just an example these are the the you
know i showed you just bcc and fcc
here they are right there's an
octahedral site this is bcc down here
so notice those are the the shaded in
atoms are the lattice
sites right bcc at the corners and in
the middle
and and now you see the the red atom is
in the middle
of goes in tight is in the middle let's
say the red atom was here and it's
moving to there and now it's in the
middle
so it might take that path as it
diffuses it's going to find
the voids diffusing atoms find the voids
right and and so if you have something
that's trying to fuse it's going to want
to find these voids this is an
octahedral site because
this is an octahedron and you can have
one of those in an fcc crystal as well
you can have an octahedral site
so in fcc you've got atoms you've got
lattice sites
in the faces but not in the center and
so its octahedral
site is here in in the tetra you've got
tetrahedral sites those are
other voids in the crystals right
we touched on this a little bit when we
talked about defects and crystals
but now i want to i want to relate it to
diffusion because
how a crystal has voids
how a crystal has voids is critical to
d how something diffuses in it whether
that something is something in the
crystal itself or something you've added
to it
right how how and how it has voids
depends on
you know the bonding the chemistry and
the the crystal structure
right um so you could answer questions
like this right these are a couple of
these are some uh uh just you know
fairly
now straightforward questions right that
you could answer
what if i had so you know if i had
carbon
is what i just showed you in alpha or
gamma iron
right well it's so i'll just write the
it's alpha iron
because it's an open
i don't need to calculate stuff i just
look up
you know alpha which one is bcc which
one is fcc and it's alpha because it's
an open bcc
structure and so the diffusion uh
barriers are going to be lower okay iron
in
alpha iron at 500 or 900 well now i've
got a temperature question
i know d is going to be higher so 900
right
900 degrees c because of temp
influence of temperature okay iron in
hydrogen
or iron or hydrogen in alpha iron it's
like what we just talked about right so
this would be particle size
right h is smaller
right and these are conceptual kind of
questions
uh what's the fourth one silicon vacancy
in silicon or helium and silicon
well for a vacancy to move you need
those kind of
same atoms to move and if the same atom
is moving
through those sites that's harder that's
harder
than if a small interstitial like
hydrogen is moving through those voids
right through those voids that's why
when you look at this iron
is orders and orders of magnitude slower
the d is orders and orders of magnitude
slower than carbon
or hydrogen right and so that's going to
be
h e and because the vacancy diffusion is
so much slower
and then five mg this is a good one
because
you know hydrogen and platinum or
hydrogen and magnesium magnesium
has a larger atomic radius
larger are atomic
right and you look it up and say they
got the same close-packed crystal
structures
but one of them has larger you know a
larger radius
what does that mean well it says
something about the voids
as well right the voids are going to be
larger
right if the remember this is happening
through the voids
this is happening through the voids this
is how batteries
are engineered this is this is why
we have a revolution in batteries
right so this is a couple of years old
there's so many great review articles on
on battery technologies right but
you know there are you can view
batteries this is the cathode by the way
what is a battery well
you know a lithium battery is basically
two sponges
right and and one of them is is is
usually carbon
yeah okay and and when you're running
your battery lithium ions are going in
right and and the carbon is so strong
and kind of
able to hold you know hold those lithium
atoms in and not break down
so we often use carbon um
on the anode side and and then when we
when we charge it up we push them back
over to where
where they came from that's the cathode
which is a lithium
compound but you know it has to be a
it has to be a material that can hold
lithium in it
hopefully at very high concentration but
also be okay to lose it
and not completely collapse okay so
but now and so you got lithium iron
phosphate
right those are the you know these ones
you've got uh manganates you've got
cobalts uh cobalt oxide materials there
are so
many battery materials they all work the
same way
the lithium if it's a lithium batteries
the lithium
is going to leave some crystal that has
lithium in it
but it's the crystal has to stay so it's
like a sponge that loses
something from it but stays intact and
that something goes over to the
the anode it gets soaked up there and
then
you know you and you can recharge
discharge recharges you're just pushing
these lithiums back and forth
right oh but you're pushing them back
and forth
you are diffusing them that's what
you're doing
you are diffusing them through whatever
structure you're putting them into
right so if it's the cathode and
and you're trying to get the lithium to
come back in or to go back out
then you can imagine that the barriers
and the dimensionality itself
are crucial what is an activation energy
for a lithium atom
in a given material and
does it take a 1d path it turns out
these can be extremely
efficient look at those they're
practically holes they're lines in the
lithium iron phosphate that's a really
nice cathode material
because you got these channels these
high conduction channels these highways
right but then you say well but maybe i
need 3d
voids maybe it shouldn't have channels
it should have voids
so it can choose more paths okay
or maybe we have planes maybe it's a
layered structure where they have these
2d planes they can travel through
what's the best well it's it's it's not
trivial
because it's it's one of these as usual
constrained optimization problems where
when you make
the pathway faster you might need to
have more voids
where you'll lose material or maybe you
make the material unstable
right so you're kind of fighting you
want it to have a really high density
but you also want it to but the the
lithium diffusion in a battery material
is related to the charge time
right that so so if you plot like here's
another
uh paper from a few years ago or if you
plot materials now here's the specific
power
and and so that's the how much power
watts per weight
here's the watt hours so that's the
energy right
per weight then and this is the charge
rate right this is this is the charge
rate
and notice so you want it to be very
very fast charging
and these are these are different
materials there's a lead acid battery
it's still in your car
right um these are nickel metal hydrides
and and so forth other technologies
here the lithium here the lithium-ion
batteries is what's in your cell phone
notice something as i get up to higher
to faster charge rates
more open voids right in the material
um i lose i lose energy density i go
this way
i don't want to go that way i want to go
this way
constrained optimization cons these are
the things
what goes into solving these problems is
calculating diffusion barriers right
and energy densities and all the other
things that matter but if you want to
target
fast charging you got to know the
diffusion barriers right
one of the number one uh challenges in
battery design
is to keep that high while continuing to
push up that way
right see polymers you could imagine
that a polymer is slower
it makes sense right because it's it's
harder as we talked about
when we talk about polymers it's harder
to make
crystalline polymers to keep a polymer
from having some amorphous
region i mean after all you got these
you know 100 000 unit long
strands of spaghetti so it kind of makes
sense that the diffusion is going to be
lower
in a polymer than in one of these
crystals right like an olivine lithium
iron phosphate
right so that makes sense but polymers
would be great because they're
lighter right and they can be flexible
right and so so we like polymer
batteries a lot we want them
for many applications right so these are
the kinds of trade-offs that you think
about and d
is right there in the center because
none of us want a battery that takes
you know two days to charge right okay
and now we get to the next part which
i'll i'll just introduce
which is now we're going to think about
time
and i and i want to set this problem up
and and then we'll we'll solve it on
on wednesday and then and then finish um
but i want to set it up because the next
thing that's related to diffusion
is time and i want to give you an
example of
how that's so important with something
called case hardening
right so if you buy a gear and you do
buy a gears all the time
whether you like it or not or know it or
not lots of stuff has gears in it
right um and and you look at the gear
closely it would look different on the
outside if you cross if you do a cross
section
most gears are going to look different
on the outside
and the reason has to do with exactly
what we just talked about
if this is an iron if this is a piece of
iron pure iron it's going to be too soft
so you're now turning this and you're
it's gotta have mechanical integrity
right and so so you gotta you gotta
make it harder but the thing is that so
if you put it in and it's pure iron it's
too soft
but now if you make it this really ultra
high strength carbon
infused steel it gets too brittle
it gets too brittle right and so you
need a balance
and one of the ways to balance the
mechanical strength of something like a
gear or
many many other materials is to harden
just the outside that's called case
hardening
the case it's the case right how do you
do it
well you get carbon you might remember
carbon going into the iron
makes it a lot harder but it also makes
it more brittle so if you made the whole
gear
the same amount of carbon infused in
iron it's going to be
too brittle if you put any on it's not
mechanically strong enough so
what you do is you very very delicately
expose this piece of iron to carbon
you harden it but just on the outside
now
how does the carbon get in diffusion it
gets
into the material through diffusion
so then the question at your gear making
plant
that you have to know is what
temperature
what temperature and how long
should i expose this gear to how much
carbon
you got concentration you got
temperature
and you got time and and if you know
that
you can actually process this material
in just the way you want and you
have to know those parameters and that
is fixed second law
so fix second law so this is these are
steel
pipes and they are going to be case
hardened
right so what's happening you got an
iron with a certain amount
of of carbon content but now i need to
add more carbon but just
to just the right amount to the exterior
of those of those iron of those steel
pipes right
how long should i do it and that is
fixed second law
which i'll write down
right so how do we figure that out well
we use the time dependent version
of fick's law and the second law
fixed
second law says that the change in
concentration
with time is equal to the diffusion
constant
times the second derivative of the
concentration
with position that's fixed second law
and so this is non-steady
state which means and and we're not
going to derive this but i do want you
to know
that this is the fixed second law
equation and how you might apply it
which is why we'll do a problem
with it but it's non-steady state and
um and that means that the concentration
is going to be a function that you're
going to get is going to be a function
of
position and time it's going to be a
function of both
so now i can answer the quick remember
before
i had to keep the i had to keep the um
you know the concentrations fixed to
apply fixed first law now i can answer
the question
well okay if i have certain parameters
right what is the concentration going to
be
what is the concentration going to be at
some time and some place
and that's exactly the question i have
to answer how much
carbon am i going to have at what
position in in the case right the case
hardening
and what position of the pipe exterior
how much carbon
am i going to have at what time how long
should i leave it in the oven
and then that's the question i'm trying
to answer and it by the way what
temperature
right and and so if you st if you the
the thing that fixed
second law helps us understand is if i
start with some
cs that's the starting concentration and
i have some uh sorry
i have a starting concentration c naught
and i expose
at the surface some higher concentration
right remember before i kept these fixed
i kept these fixed and i got a flux now
i'm gonna be able to get this
so this is like this is like okay this
line here is time equals zero but now
i can time one i can actually get this
profile
time two
time three that's the position through
some surface
okay so what so this is what fixed
second law tells us it tells us these
profiles
the concentration in the material and
it just simply it just simply is a
time-dependent version
of diffusion okay what we're going to do
is we're going to pick up with this
we'll do this example of case hardening
we'll do a few more
comments on the class i'll tell you a
little bit about the final
and please bring your laptops on
wednesdays for the last 15 minutes
we'll reserve for you to do evaluations
you